bene tutti ragazzi venuti questo video
sono fa vj e siamo tornati oggi su
minecraft harcourt episodio six let's go
come sei arrivato lì schifoso monaci
greci un pezzo noche della lava in campo
ma non riesce più a far sapere che siamo
altissimi non so come ma cede la lava
come fai a forza parte mori e devi
quella che non devi andati sotto per c'è
la lav ha subito a meno che lo devi
prendere il esatto
no no no no i full of pop
no non ho capito anch'io questo che è
successo
i fulmini ciano 6 forse non di toccare
il legno loren che legno non lo so non
ho capito è vero o se magari 9.63 di
sopportare le rispetta eh sì insomma è
vero
secondo me se non tocchi in legno non ti
butta giù chi strano ma come si fa ce
l'ho fatta c'è qualche cosa ma come fai
apprende era un trick shot nel morire a
guardarti sono morto perché soffitto la
parola esatta 65 era cortissime suo
livello dai o amen 60 40 46 la power a
lavorare inventa che sto valutando poi
difficile perché non si capisce da dove
dove puoi andare a ventate uscendo
allora non diamo via fiat
no no no no io guardavo a grana guarda
che nervi
il pacco una volta poi dai proviamo
allora perchè i viola ce l'ho fatta
eccomi eccomi vai avanti si domanda
secca di carriera d'acqua un casino atto
di cui ecco perfetto questo quanto tipo
venga essere alla moglie anch'io
tranquillo guarda ciao amico al prossimo
livello dai the huffington livello ok
amico guarda qua guardo giù incredibile
no no ho scoperto una roba incredibile
tra l'altro nel fare stack agata che che
che uova cosa sbagliato caduto ma penso
non più libro che figata
quindi alla fine devi veramente fare
così nella cacate che possiamo fare
perfetto aiuto aiuto da quando si sa
fare la promessa a fare la presenza fare
non so fare non so fare non so fare
perfetto ci ho fatto a non ce l'ho fatta
non so come siamo sul lavoro sulla liana
no le liane no non mi manca non per
niente julian è amico mio amico mio le
liane ne devi saper usare di essere il
nuovo taranzano cosa facciamo
più facile a quota 67 all'acqua il
livello ecco bravo il livello qua e
molto molto easy prove prima
non mi caricatore cioè fatta già fatta
davvero mi sono trovato non è vero
e sì se vai vieni dritto esatto dall
idea di fare hai visto che bravo non so
se noi centrali il passaggio segreto non
avevo visto bravo scovatore di segreti
bravissimo vai vai vai amico spaccatutto
aiutami a fargli avuto pochissimo no
sono vivo muori quadri forte anche il
drop belli fare tutto il drop si slocca
spegni ti grazie a un david o
mamma mia che rischio che rischio il
pezzettino finale un casino e amico
l'olio porno allora non potete questo no
no sono vivo o lo siamo adesso o finirà
maisto livello insomma non lo so è
un'ansia allucinante però che se muori
con la vasta una prima esatto scusami
pensa volessi toccarmi però sei salvo
grazie amico ce la fa subito
ora che stiamo veramente un fire oggi
c'era giocato quindi va bene
69 amico e non è quello che pensi la
donna che casino suo livello
che figata se tocchi l'acqua mi sa che
ripartì da zero
però è difficile st barth amico non l'ho
ancora vista ce l'ho fatta e difficile è
difficile poi da fare subito non ho
capito eh ma skill a ma c'è una liana
italiana la seguiamo anche se non ci
vado a nozze con le dia guarda
è una volta che arrivi di questo salti
angolari che mi piacciono tanto sono
caduto
rifai tutto le 26 alla fine 70 perfetto
bravissimo baracche di salvo di salvo e
chi va bene vedi e uno per uno e forse
anche prima
allora ferma affetto ma io le pianelle
detesto non hanno senso di esistere il
suo gioco mi spiace unico altro tanto io
valore su un albero è l'unico loro c'era
troppo sai a questo al vantaggio
all'ultimo madonna guardalo volta player
proprio lui ma io la maglia io ho messo
la mia maglia al contrario
me ne sono accorta adesso messo la mia
voglia il contrario se stavo la maglia
contrae scusate amici
let's go non era esattamente quello che
dovevi fare amico eh si la diana e
quell'amico prove roda appunto molto più
in alto a ecco perché non ce l'ha fatta
è saltato lariana direttamente 71 hanno
ben capito scusami dobbiamo andare di
qua perché così di ok no perché la prima
volta che c'è questo bio ma se così
vogliamo chiamarlo non lo so davis
altare di saltare sulle staccionate
amico non è facile però se sei un bravo
giocatore lo farai pedica poi andare gli
utenti di sopra magari sei puoi tagliare
42 livelli guardare al sarebbe stato
carino 72 comunque tutto questo è
ficcata a gara
non pensavo potesse arrivare
direttamente alla sua opera e anch'io
però vai vai se guardiamo volume hai
visto sia all'estero che l'est che sta
chi se amico si tu dove sei e avanti
spieghi sta andando a fuoco
non è vero nodo marito no qua
deduco che tu sia morto andiamo che è
l'emozione c'è un buco lì
vieni amico ti aspetto a sei piani
ecco lo slime se tutti i salti come cubo
normale è veramente una tortura
abbastanza sottili che non serve una
rosa ad ok stava andando avanti ragazzi
siamo veramente messi bene oggi 73 ce ne
sono 100 alla fine non immagino che
duriamo sei anni ok slang di qua mamma
mia che provate una donna spettacolo
perfetto vedo la fine
vedo la fine vedo la luce veda la luce e
74 live view allora devi usare per forza
il carrello però devi scendere a una
certa dove vai
non lo so esattamente quella roba lì che
hai fatto puoi farlo anche quel carrello
e da quano vieni amico o c'è il coso
l'aliante lei li tra quello che ho
ricordi ha forse devi devi seguire la
nava capitolo può essere proviamo a fare
seguì la lava e giusto o più o meno gli
parlò quello di qualcuno fatto io per la
non sono io non mi viene anche spiegato
la litra cioè non mi ha neanche detto
ciao ti spiego fermi
mamma mia lotta play è fatto sì non so
come ho fatto lo giuro mamma mi ha fatto
una roba incredibile che devi girare
fortissimo che figata che il resto
livello mi è piaciuto un sacco
cioè non è che sia finito sono bravo
bravo chi sei core seguendo è arrivato
molto bene io non posso ok come dove si
vota no no no no no no io non la faccio
parte non sto vedendo un uomo tranquillo
che io stia fermo qua mette la capannina
pianto di una la tenda e via
ma no dai a perché sentite le
trasportava l'inizio io meno male che
non l'ho fatto senza pensarci se non mi
sarei cagato addosso tantissimo buon
perfetto è andata bene poi c'è la liana
ok ci metta finestra livello che figata
siamo veramente in alto qua giù lo vedo
un sacco di cose siamo saliti tantissimo
tante tant'è che c'è lancia addirittura
in inverno figata amico
le entrate al 75esimo livello è
bellissima
c'è non è come te l'aspetti vieni da
regalo 70 cia non è ancora 75 cosa però
è vedi che abbiamo saltato accenti anti
ha fatto esattamente vedere quando entri
nella nuova parte di ps estivo questo 36
8 ciao mentre lui si guarda il no ha
conosciuto manderà in onda gli devi
andare qua e poi da quale di far
qualcosa le staccionate che pirla
ho mica capito ok va bè cosa vedo
ma vabbè impossibile ma a tempo sono
cosa va bene cosa amico solo 76
ho fatto una roba blu
no non so cosa sia successo ti prego di
rivedere il video devi di vedere il
video perché è successa una roba
stranissima osc impatto un livello ero
brain ci aiuta in parkour
ok si è fatto tutto è bravissimo io non
ho fatto niente per la merita il capo
dito in questa 20 minuti credo di fare
qua no bravo però il fatto al volo sì
perché abbiamo devo saltare direttamente
sul cosa bravissimo ma c'è andato bene e
qua
la cosa va avanti di saltare su qualcosa
di roccia esatto dall idea di fare salti
di roccia fatica di roccia bravo pietro
che figata amico uno sla in gigante
vieni con noi bellissimo pouncey
leggonline pollici palla mi ha dato
ancora mi ha dato anche una cimenta come
se l'avessi fatto la prima volta ma un
singolo us line ma perché in forza
intende slime lay line si si hai a mare
c'è un problema di me se cadi non posso
dire chi lo puoi fare ma non può di
pronto sei pronto barbari schiaccia ma
cosa ci però io amico è successa una
roba strana ma mi sa che è proprio
quello che dovevo fare allora geronimo
dovevo fare veramente così e io nello
sbaglio sto facendo giusto perfetto da
26 toccherà arrivare iorio ecco ecco ci
ho messo sei anni allora però siamo
stati bravi a 78 in tutto questo se non
anche più guardate cosa no vabbè ma io
il ghiaccio lo odio giusto giocò liane
ghiaccio sono da odiare perfetto madonna
e ce la fa a 79 ragazzi cosa al
piacevole fatto sì tutto è la madonna
infilano fortissimo a araba ceralacca
google si sentiva 100 watt e pirlo ecco
adesso invece sì
adesso ti saresti fatto di andare qua
qua qua in basso sotto di me qua ok poi
l'altro nell'altro ottavo qua ha mai
pronto vieni qua dove andiamo
la tartarughina che fa guarda se scopri
cosa devi fare dopo ti regalo un
cervello non so
impossibile ma allora è difficilissimo
solo capirlo come avanti avanti livello
80 amico 80 80 metri crescere speck e
sono pure morto i ragazzi che sarà la
mia voglia di vivere di giocare con
pietro a questo gioco tranquillo e
sereno e dove non ci facciamo i dispetti
quindi è un bel mi piace anche ai vari
social che come negli descrizione che in
realtà ci sono di stagione però laicato
la mia pagina di strano se non sa dove
si rischia temi e noi ci vediamo come
sempre ad un prossimo
video suo vino da ragazzi
[Musica]